Only during the full moon or new moon is the
tide low enough.
That's when the aquaculture farmers of Tampolo
Bay head to their enclosures to take inventory.
Workers from the NGO Blue Ventures monitor
the animals' growth.
This is the group that first proposed raising
sea cucumbers to the villagers ten years ago.
Once the creatures reach 400 grams, they're
ready for sale.
There are rules for maintaining the enclosures.
We devised them with the farmers.
For example, no one may enter another farmer's
enclosure without his or her permission.
Fishing of any kind is banned.
Crabs are the one exception.
THEY can be caught, because otherwise they'd
eat the sea cucumbers.
All these rules serve to protect the sea.
Before aquaculture began here, hardly any
fish were left in this lagoon.
Today there's a greater variety of fish, snails
and crabs.
That's because sea cucumbers act like natural
filters.
By ingesting sand, they purify it --removing
organic waste, microalgae and bacteria.
In a country where 70 percent of the population
lives in poverty, this village is experiencing
some rare prosperity... thanks to sea cucumbers.
Seraphine Kiry was one of the first aquaculture
farmers here in 2009.
Before the sea cucumber farm started I had
no way to raise my standard of living.
Since I got my own enclosure, I have enough
money to send my two children to school.
And I've bought a few nice things for the
house.
And I have a herd of goats now.
The farmers pay 16 cents for the newborn sea
creatures.
But after nine months of feeding their way
through the sand, the now-mature sea cucumbers
are worth a dollar 30.
In Asia and elswhere, dried sea cucumbers
are a delicacy.
Cultivating them benefits not only the farmers,
but the entire bay and all its marine life.